officially called the guidance Patrol
these green and white minivans are a
familiar sight cruising the streets
the special force was established in
2006. its only job to park at Major
intersections and thoroughfares to issue
warnings to women deemed to be flowering
Iran's religious dress codes
according to the attorney general the
same institution that set up the
morality police has shut it down
on Saturday a statement published in a
local newspaper announced the Judiciary
is already working on a draft proposal
for amendments to how authorities
enforce laws pertaining to Chastity and
hijab following recent events the
relevant bodies are looking for a
prudent solution
since the death of Masa amini in a
Detention Facility in September protests
have erupted across the country many of
which have turned violent human rights
groups say more than 440 people have
been killed and another 17 000 arrested
the interior Ministry puts the death
toll at 200 including security forces
massa's death has sparked a massive
outcry some women are publicly snubbing
the headscarf that has been compulsory
for women and girls as young as the age
of seven since 1983. analysts say it's
the direct result of a change in
societal Norms
what we've witnessed in Tehran in recent
days is women coming out in public
without their hijab and are not being
confronted by authorities when you can't
enforce a law then eventually this rule
will be put aside I think the change
will mostly happen in methods of
enforcement but not changing the law
according to the latest survey published
by the parliament 60 to 70 percent of
Iranian women do not follow the Islamic
dress code strictly in public and since
September scenes like this have become
common
while the issue of mandatory hijab is
still very much a rule in Iran the
suspension of the so-called morality
police could be seen as a move by
authorities to appease women the
question now is will it be enough
Tehran